this is not a video about JK Rowling
however we are going to have to start
with her in order to have this
conversation
a little while ago I released a video
detailing a breakdown and my thoughts on
some of JK Rowling's more recent actions
statements and expressed thoughts
and if you aren't familiar with that
video you can see it there again you
don't necessarily have to because this
video is not actually about JK Rowling
however there was something that
happened repeatedly in my comment
section and something that I also saw
happening on Twitter that I want to talk
about and I'm going to use the response
to that JK Rowling video in order to
frame this conversation
so
very briefly JK Rowling is a beloved
children's author author of the Harry
Potter franchise and as a result her
work means a great deal to a great many
people
over the last
over two years now she has been
demonstrating a very high degree of
active transphobia not only expressing
her own transphobic thoughts but also
platforming boosting financially
supporting other transphobic organizers
events groups creators
Etc
again I'm not trying to break down all
of this but the reason I bring that up
is because that is something that upset
a great deal of people not just people
who have an issue with anyone being
transphobic but a great number of her
fans
because Harry Potter being a story about
someone who felt like an outcast who
felt like they did not belong finding a
place where he finally fit in yeah that
spoke to a pretty large number of queer
people including trans people
and it's been difficult for a lot of
them
but the way some of them appear to be
trying to process this
is by examining or attempting to examine
Ms Rowling's mental health I have seen
it as both something that is presented
as maybe some kind of explanation and
maybe we shouldn't be as hard on her
because commenters will claim that she
appears to be having some kind of mental
health issue there are those who are not
using it as any kind of Defense but are
still pointing to it as if it explains
the degree of her actions and the things
that she's saying
that is what I want to talk about
this go-to of Mental Health
as an attempt to explain the actions of
a public figure
there are two major things that I want
to cover here the first is that unless
the public figure in question has
disclosed information about their mental
health or any possible mental illness
that they are currently or have
historically been dealing with
then that is absolutely none of your
business
at all
some public figures have talked about
their mental health that's something
that's been in the conversation with
someone like Kanye West but with Ms
Rowling
she has not made any comments along that
and someone's Mental Health
if they have not shared information
about that
is not
any of your business at all
there are multiple reasons for this
the first is
you you are not a clinical psychologist
you are not a psychiatrist you are not
in a position to actually diagnose her
with anything
you are someone with a pop culture
understanding at Best of various mental
conditions or maybe even base it off
your own experience with mental illness
but you are not qualified to diagnose
her or anyone with any mental condition
and before anyone attempts to write in a
comment well I actually have a
background or I am a practicing
psychiatrist or whatever else if that is
the case
then you are unethical and should not be
allowed to practice any kind of medicine
because if you actually have that
education if you actually have that
background then you should understand
how unethical it is to attempt to
diagnose a person you do not know and
have never sat down had a session with
or even read the detail notes of someone
who has
and yeah I am flat out calling any and
every supposed expert who has ever
showed up on a news show to diagnose a
celebrity or political figure with a
mental health condition unethical
there's a reason that pretty much all of
those people are either professors or
they are authors or they're not
currently practicing
because it's not ethical for them to
diagnose someone they do not know
so that is the first thing
whether or not JK Rowling or anyone who
has not disclosed their own mental
health information has a mental illness
or not is none of your business
absolutely not not even slightly
so that's the first really big problem
but for a moment
let's move past that
and take on board okay
so maybe she has a mental health
condition maybe she has had some event
or some breakdown or some sort of change
within her mental state that has caused
her to either believe the things that
she believes or to express them in the
way she chooses to express them
to what degree does that actually matter
and I mean that very sincerely why does
it matter in the case of someone like
this in the case of someone whose
actions and continued platforming and
bolstering of deeply harmful thoughts
ideas and policies
does it matter if they're doing it for
mental health reasons because whether or
not that's true has no bearing on the
damage that is being done by her actions
whether it is because she's acting on
sincerely held beliefs or it's because
she has early onset dementia her actions
what she is doing is just as damaging it
is no less damaging for having a
different cause than a sincerely held
belief
why does it matter
and I'm not just asking that as a
rhetorical I intend to address that
because
people appear to be doing this
floating these ideas these armchair
diagnoses
as a way in some manner of not having to
address something
now exactly what that could be might
vary I suspect for some people
especially fans for whom Harry Potter is
important to them maybe even still and
to be clear I've said before
I don't begrudge anyone continuing to
love Harry Potter especially any Harry
Potter related items that they already
owned
I do still take issue with anyone who
puts money towards anything with her
name on it from this point on and going
forward
but I don't think you have to get rid of
the Harry Potter stuff you already had
I haven't it's packed away it's in the
attic I don't want to look at it I
haven't had the heart to get rid of mine
I do understand that
but
I fear that
people with that degree of attachment of
nostalgia of love
for her work
they want a reason to not have to think
that the person who made something that
they love has awful thoughts and is
doing awful things
they want there to be a reason
that doesn't impact the work
and if in theory
JK Rowling came down with something over
the last three years
that would detach her current actions
from the person who wrote those books
I understand the impulse to do that
but there's no evidence to support it
and your desire
to not want the person now speaking out
and taking such action against trans
people as JK Rowling is doing to be the
same person who wrote books that means
so much to you your desire to have them
be different people
doesn't make it so and it can't and that
can be very hard to cope with there's a
certain amount of guilt that can hit as
a result of that as you find yourself
wondering
this person
if something didn't happen
that made them like this
then to some degree
they were always like this or they at
least always had the potential to become
this on their own
what does that say about me that I like
their work what does that say about me
that I couldn't detect that something
was off
and
while that sense of guilt I think is
very human
it's also not your responsibility to
have noticed these things
but you're your own emotions and
thoughts might still try and hold you in
some way responsible and in a case like
that
wanting it to be a mental illness can be
a defense mechanism
I went through this earlier to a certain
degree with Mel Gibson not that I deeply
loved everything the man ever did but
Braveheart was one of my favorite movies
ever
and then the kind of person Mel Gibson
was became very very evident and looking
back over the years I now realize that's
who he always was
and it makes things uncomfortable
it's not a fun thing to think
he didn't become this he was always this
and I didn't see it
but again rationally it wasn't my
responsibility Braveheart came out in
the mid 90s I was a teenager
how was I supposed to know
it doesn't have to be rational to still
weigh on you I do understand that
but there is no indication of mental
illness
with her but even Beyond something like
that to make a
another comparison and I don't think I
can not make this comparison
when I see people
diagnosing her with something
another thing that can be an impact of
that and probably an unintended one is
that it removes
the responsibility of societal
influences
or the systems of celebrity and
empowerment of capitalism or any other
system from having any degree of
responsibility
if JK Rowling has a mental illness
then what's going on
is nobody's fault
it is not the fault of her fans for
sticking beside her and empowering her
and praising her as perfect and Flawless
and going after anyone who said that
maybe Harry Potter wasn't the best thing
ever and contributing to boosting her
ego and reassuring her no you're not
wrong you're great you're awesome you're
wonderful
which is something I did a video about
some years back
to say that it's mental illness removes
the responsibility
of the groups that she is associating
with
and if it removes any responsibility
from those groups then it removes any
responsibility of the political system
that those groups are attempting to
influence the political system that
is allowing her voice to actively push
the needle in favor of transphobia in
the UK which is subsequently influencing
active transphobia elsewhere including
in the U.S
if she's mentally ill then we don't have
to examine anything else all we have to
do
is get a diagnosis figure out what's
wrong with her or even if we can't we
just go well you can't fix crazy
and it's true
but crazy doesn't exist in a vacuum
crazy shouldn't be able to do the kind
of damage and continued harm that JK
Rowling is doing unless there are other
failures elsewhere
unless there was a failure
of the defense of Human Rights unless
there was a failure of a political
system to guard itself against the
farthest and most hostile Fringe
elements within its own population
if she's just crazy
then there's no work to be done
we don't have to worry about anybody
else we don't have to do anything else
and as crass as this comparison may be
it is like how every time there was a
mass shooting in the U.S
those who don't want to deal with gun
legislation immediately jump to mental
illness
because if a mass shooter is crazy
then well you can't fix crazy so there's
nothing to be done we don't have to
change the system that allowed this to
be as damaging as it was
now am I accusing JK Rowling of having
the same impact as a mass shooter no I
am not doing that
as I said this video is not even truly
about her
this is about the inclination towards
people anybody
to jump towards mental illness for any
reason
whether it's because you're doing it
because you need some explanation
because it doesn't make any sense to you
otherwise whether you're doing it in
order to avoid any kind of
responsibility that might be on the part
of things other than this one individual
that maybe those things need a dressing
whatever it may be
it's still none of your business
and it's also not relevant
it's not relevant to the damage that is
happening and it obscures other problems
to suggest that that is what is going on
and the other thing the very simple fact
and this is something that I think
really needs to be remembered
about anytime anybody is behaving in a
way that makes no sense to you and that
is that
you don't need a mental illness to be a
bad person
you can be
a massively influential transphobic
person
you don't need a mental illness to be
that
you can be
a white supremacist
who picks up a gun
and shoots the people that they believe
is
making the country worse
without having mental illness
some people are just [ __ ]
and they don't need a mental illness for
that to be the case
so please in my comments specifically
going forward in reference to JK Rowling
or anyone else
that has not publicly disclosed some
degree of mental illness or struggles
with mental health
don't diagnose them in my comments
don't distract from what's actually
going on
and if you feel an inclination to do
that even outside my comments section
stop and think why
why do you care
why does it matter
why do you want it to be mental illness
ask yourself those questions
and hopefully we can move forward
thank you for listening this was a
fairly frustrated ramble for me but this
has been on my mind
for a little bit now
and I needed to get this off my chest
patreon is how you can support me and
what I do any amount that you are able
to support is of immense assistance and
there are various perks for doing so
there's also a link to the patreon down
in this description there are links to
other things that I do besides this
YouTube channel
but don't worry too much about that
comments down below like share subscribe
any comments Keepers keep them
respectful no personal attacks against
me other commenters JK Rowling or anyone
else
but the thing that I really want you to
remember
is that you
are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
Council
is adjourned
end of the video so I got a shout out my
top patrons Robin Moore Zubin mcfula
Tarak the thing that goes doing in the
anime Oliver B Angus bjornison Melinda
Walters imudelki the oatha Boyd catoria
toyololi Becky Sparks for nabilox the
poodle Zach Tracy scrabot angry Casper
Tim price Adam r d l Taylor Shayla
gourlay and Brendan Larose
thanks for your support if you want to
hear me probably mispronounce your name
as well check out the rewards on the
patreon
what you doing there